Hi.
I'm Chris Broadfoot.
I'm an engineer on the Google
Maps Developer Relations team.
In this tutorial, I'll be
showing you how to get started
with the Google Places API.
The Google Places API gives
you access to Google's
database of over 80
million places.
There's worldwide coverage and
detailed information about
each and every place.
It's completely free to use, and
in this tutorial, I'll be
showing you how to
get started.
Before we begin, let me show
you one of my favorite
websites built with
the Places API.
mapofthedead.com shows you
how to survive the zombie
apocalypse.
The first thing you'll notice
is that it doesn't look
anything like Google Maps.
These guys are using a great
map style that gives you a
fantastic undead
look and feel.
Places that are important during
the zombie apocalypse
are displayed and marked on the
map, such as gun stores,
grocery stores, airports,
and doctors.
I can move the character around,
and based on where I
place him, new results are
marked on the map.
I can also use the textbooks
at the top of the page to
select a new location.
This is the best time to use
Places Autocomplete.
A feature I'll be showing you
how to use in a moment.
You, too, can build apps like
the one I just showed.
It's worth reading through the
documentation to get a good
understanding of the
capabilities.
In this tutorial I'll be
demonstrating some of the
features of the Places API.
The Google Places API is
accessible via our Web Service
from the language of your choice
or from your website
using the library in the
Maps JavaScript API.
The Web Service can
send responses
formatted as JSON or XML.
Today, I'll be using
the JSON version.
To start using the Google Places
API, you first need to
sign up for a Places API key.
This allows us to issue you
more quota when your
application exceeds the courtesy
limit of 1,000
requests per day.
First, visit the developer
console found over on the
Google Developers website.
You'll need to create a project,
then enable the
Places API.
Read through the terms
of service carefully.
There are some important points,
including some about
use of data returned
from the API.
Once you've done that, you can
now obtain your key from the
API access screen.
This key will be used for all
web service requests.
Let's take a look at Places
Auotocomplete.
Google Places Autocomplete
allows you to add similar
functionality to
the Google Maps
search box on your website.
Places and addresses are
suggested as I type into the
standard HTML input box.
As I begin typing 1600
Amphitheatre Parkway, Google's
Mountain View headquarters, I
get suggestions based on my
partial input.
Note that the matching substring
is highlighted on
each suggestion.
Using Autocomplete via the
JavaScript library is simple.
First, you need to include the
Places library when you load
the Google Maps JavaScript
API.
Just add libraries equals Places
to your bootstrap.
Add Autocomplete to an existing
input element in your
page by passing in the element
as a parameter to the
Autocomplete's constructor.
Autocomplete functionality
is now attached
to the input element.
To be notified of when a user
selects a place, listen to the
place changed event on the
Autocomplete object.
Details of the selected place
can then be obtained inside an
event listener.
Just call Get Place on the
Autocomplete object to
retrieve the details about
the selected place.
In this example, we simply
output three fields--
the formatted address, the
URL, and location.
There are many other fields
that you can use in your
application.
Autocomplete is also available
as a web service accessible
from any programming language.
Using the web service opens up
more creative possibilities of
displaying and augmenting
results.
Just use your favorite HTTP
package or library.
Send an HTTP get request.
Include the partial input
from the user.
In addition, there are two
required parameters for each
web service query--
key and sensor.
Use the key that you generated
previously from
the developer console.
The sensor must be set to true
if the location is derived
from any sensor such as a GPS.
Otherwise, it's safe
to set it to false.
The response contains a status
code and a list of
predictions.
Each prediction will be
comprised of a description,
which is a string that you
should present to the user, a
breakdown of the terms, which
make up the suggestion, a list
of the substrings matched
to the user input--
you can highlight it in
your user interface--
and an ID, which we'll
ignore for now.
You also get a place reference,
which you can use
to fetch additional
Place details.
Place details can be fetched
using a place reference.
Again, send an HTTP
get request to
the details end point.
The only other required
parameters are key and sensor,
which I mentioned previously.
Attributes of the place
will be returned.
Some sample output
is shown here.
And the response will contain
a status code, data
attributions formatted as
HTML, and a place result
structure containing detailed
information such as name,
location, formatted instruction
address, category
phone number, amongst
other attributes.
Look at the documentation
for a complete list.
While a details request is
available using the JavaScript
library, it's not necessary to
use it if you're using the
Autocomplete control.
Details are returned
automatically upon selection
of a place in the dropdown.
You might still want to store
the reference for later
retrieval of the
place details.
It's possible to perform
some filtering on the
Autocomplete API.
The first kind of filter
is the type filter.
This refines predictions based
on the type of result.
There are currently
four options--
geocode, establishment,
regions, and cities.
Geocode will return addresses
and regions, and
establishments will
return businesses.
The next kind of filter allows
restriction of predictions to
a single country.
Simply add the components
parameter.
In this example, all
Autocomplete predictions are
restricted to France.
This is also valid on the
Autocomplete control.
Just set the component
restrictions property.
As I begin typing California,
the Autocomplete control will
only offer me suggestions
in France.
Autocomplete is optimized to
select a place based on
partial input.
It's optimized for very low
latency so that users see
results immediately after
every key press.
Places searches are
more powerful.
Complete search criteria
is at your disposal.
Send an HTTP get query to
the search end point.
You should specify location
and a radius.
You will receive a status code,
data attributions in
HTML format, and an array
of place results.
You'll notice that compared to
Autocomplete responses, much
more information is returned
about each place.
Places search is also
available from
the JavaScript API.
Simply create a place of service
object, then call the
search function.
You'll need to pass in a
callback function that will be
called with the place results.
In this example, we simply print
the name of types of
each place that's returned.
It's also possible to restrict
your search by category by
using the types of parameter.
We support more than 130
types, including bar,
restaurant, lodging, shop,
and many more.
You can see the complete list in
our Places reference docs.
In this example, the query
provided searches for ATMs
around the Sydney central
business district.
Sometimes, the type of place you
want to search for is not
included in our place types.
For example, if you'd like to
search for surf schools, you
can use the keyword parameter.
The places API will match the
keyword provided against all
known text associated with a
place, including its website
and user reviews.
It's also useful to refine
a type search.
For example, if you'd like
to search for Italian
restaurants, you can do a
search for types equals
restaurant and set keyword
to Italian.
Places search results can
also be refined by exact
matches of the name.
Just specify the
name parameter.
In the previous examples,
results were ranked according
to their prominent score.
Alternatively, results may be
ranked by distance from the
center of the query.
Just specify the rank
by parameter.
When using distance ranking,
you must also specify some
other search criteria.
In example here, we used
distance ranking and keyword
filtering to find the closest
sushi restaurant.
This was just an overview of
the Google Places API.
There are many more details
and features that you can
explore over on the Google
Developers website.
Thanks for listening, and I
look forward to seeing the
apps that you develop.